Oh
so freakin way okay let's get let's get
up this string
yeah I already go so I'm Brody go tell
on road that everybody wears with I
dunno I'm streaming by the way I'm just
getting the link and sharing out you
bulls
tweet then face the bookie boom okay I'm
all yours let me get up the chat about a
chat
Merry Christmas hey guys feels like it's
been a while so what just happened I was
in America the last last week last week
oh look this beer on the table I want
this right here yes I found this under
my bed the other day I was like ah look
away this on the stream Christmas dream
because it's kind of Christmas nearly
yes I am one of those annoying people
don't judge me it's December okay hey
Kevin hey Jim hey ty hey Kevin hey dude
101 hey Kai and Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas to you too
I got a massive big bag today sent
through the post of like a lot of
Christmas presents that I've been buying
so much because I'm I just got a new
niece I am yeah I had the news like a
few days ago that I got a new niece was
born
she's like weeks old so I brought her a
little dinosaur teddy bear that rattles
and stuff so I think babies would like
that don't know but anyway I'm excited
but yeah even more exciting DLC for
Resident Evil finally came out I know
it's had of the DLCs but this was like
supposed to be the main one with you
know Chris Redfield so we're gonna be
playing it and I'm excited and I didn't
really want to put this off the to long
because I'm gonna keep this up live on
the channel so I mean I don't want
people are watching afterwards being
like
she's talking crap but I do do that a
lot
dudu so yeah hey Mustafa hey Minh hey
lasered valise Rodriguez seep Wow
I'm sorry if I butchered your name which
I probably did let's play oh let me know
about the audio so if I'm too loud the
game's too loud let me know hopefully
it's okay
well this is fun okay
there is ya do game
different tones he can't be changed mood
game argh I shall do easy or normal you
know me I start the screaming I'm like
ah but then again I did I did easy when
I played the evil within either Brett my
decision and decision now because it's
way too easy it's no hard
kevin says normal oh okay my son please
don't make me luck in fear Chris feels a
high profile PSS its BSA a member who's
evolved many bioterrorism crisis over an
empty career now the new umbrella reborn
missed it you guys can watch it back if
they found out they were called that is
it really can we begin I can't help
we've got work to do
mr. creepy dude I miss playing this game
the amount of friends I've forced to
play this game
because I'd love to watch them scream
because I scream no no the winters has
been secured he's alive and well
considering he's next on my list my hit
list
okay Christmas to this
I gotta say though I don't know much
about the Resident Evil more because I
got bored when I got all actually
alright I'm in the mind how many men did
we lose
okay we start after the gun this is good
but also bad because that means that you
know monsters could be anywhere I like
when I start up and I have no weapons
cuz then I'm like okay nothing's gonna
happen yet but I'm guessing this DLC
goes more for the action that Resident
Evil kind of progressed into having
because ice oh my god already oh my god
this is gonna be terrible
do I have my oh I think it's gonna crawl
at me then all right I can punch enemies
oh wait turn around
but stop messing around okay how do I uh
okay punch punch punch Oh
they come out of the ground no okay
which what am I going oh you know that
way obviously not this way either
obviously up this way with the monster
came from cheat jump scared - I was
having troubles with one I'm gonna hit
ya oh my god
any idea what Lucas is up to down here
let's hope those men haven't become a
part of those experiments can i Newt can
I jump I can't even jump oh I have
grenades though like I don't think I can
date oh this looks like the right way
okay
then we go faster here believe me
it's too late we're both walking out of
here where are they you just kill Ron
move Oh Jose
I can hardly see anything oh I'm trying
don't know water just picked up I can't
see anything
there's no time I don't wanna give that
[ __ ] a head start you're a freaking
idiot with the bone on your arm he's
like in control of you doesn't matter if
you've got a head start or not oh wait
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
where's the button where's button
are you sure you just don't want to
recruit them say here of time hey JimBob
hey Dan they weren't I wouldn't be here
working with umbrellas gonna take some
getting used to sure
whatever I got the hammer okay how do we
crouch
slave weight once I do I need to store
anything I've got a model the model
shotgun designed to the sole purpose of
illuminating bio weapons sounds like I
might either um what all hangar shotgun
ammo definitely need that lesser
regarding goals should I read it no I
can't
briefing document yeah whatever oh I'm
sure I can figure out what I'm doing
wait one sec before the kids clone
button let's save the game mm-hmm hey
Michael and justice was it you wrong
this release in 1996 it's quite old
Danny I man is old I used to play the
ones on ps1 I used to go around my
friend's house I'm going to be up all
night playing the ps1 games like I'm
what some of those like stars I mean
that was the last one I probably played
oh thank you so much to breathe that pen
yeah Christmas presents did you come
across any of those British youtubers I
mentioned last time the Kaizen came in
world no I haven't I I left the country
for a bit so I've been like super busy
and my dissertation deadline not the
final but the fresh draft is due on
Friday so I've been like very busy with
them think yourself I don't I don't like
youtubers don't just kind of come across
it well maybe they do but maybe you've
got to be more sociable than I am I'm
not very sociable
I don't think gamers are very suitable I
need to go to more gaming events I think
like yeah that's probably how I'll meet
them so I'll look for more like gaming
YouTube events or whatever um what do I
want to use
what what do I want to use I don't think
I've used under this hmm okay let's just
look around for us
looks like I might be step up on the
other side
hmm
needs more coins okay okay so these some
coins I don't have any kind of moment
and I gave you these yeah I can
what the hell happened that
Oh shite was not supposed to do that how
do i dumb it a waste of things okay so I
got good thing I'm supposed to go here
yeah like five minutes into the game oh
my god Kevin if you met Jordan again no
I haven't actually no I have a ma'am
again okay this is the first time that
Kevin has watched this game well yeah
cuz it was out today
so anyway right let's not go in there
let's try this one
okay this it's nice and light which I
appreciate you okay in there don't worry
I'm gonna find the key to this thing and
get you out of there
gotta shoot it
okay let me go obviously the keys down
here
up up here
okay cities with food oh my god
oh my god okay wait wait can I just like
hit ya sorry that was like a frustration
screaming gonna kill you where's my
knife okay [ __ ] this up my boys a bar
fight
and again
wasting on myself hey why is this so
freakin many of these oh you're dead oh
my god
okay really
that can't be my health gauge no way I
need to find me some ammo there better
be some ammo I mean I just killed a
bunch of things thank you yes thank you
Oh
die with one shot hi yes
that's way too easy
do you guys think we're the ones the big
claws yeah I know they're the strong
ones right your health is the heartbeat
monitor but it's I just don't get it
like why is it so green no no no this is
like a slow regeneration thing which I'm
very happy about it yes okay I know I'm
just I got the I got that the crank I'm
just looking around
and all the things yes need all this
stuff
our house and this is what the print
goes once I just let me have a look
around oh there's a clown door don't
know if I want to go in here yeah I'll
find it it's behind me where is that
singing drum where is it
I didn't pick it out right what where
the bloody hell is it right one sec I'm
just gonna move my head so I can
actually see what I'm doing I'm sorry
one second
okay I'm back so where's that crank
other why couldn't I see that before but
I just going pass it look there we go
okay looks like I'm going in oh it was
the key to this door bye oh maybe both
what else do you need
so you need like some soap hour or
something
I don't know actually
open the door get on the floor everybody
walk the dinosaur way so courteous
um what else could you be needing that I
haven't found yet
ha okay
so Johnny Mookie oh this looks like a
mighty mighty monster and I'm just
casual eating it but maybe I don't have
to kill him
maybe shinies ah oh my god
don't kill me I can't even run away oh
okay right that way where is my um no no
no no where is my freaking grenade oh my
god I cannot run away from this dude
shoot no why are you freaking me what is
a robot okay okay that's fine
[ __ ] grub the key hey got here ones
faster what is wrong with you man okay
that's good oh no I just remembered I
didn't go to the clam room so ah
yes I saw the death stranding trailer
yes it freaking confused the hell army
but apparently when he falls into the
water that is when it's game over but
it's not very but she's still played
everything's all right now
and it's just really want you to think
I'm just the bait why don't you tell me
this before weighs down the waste of
madam I've got the key [ __ ] you know my
real friends I'm a master party okay
maybe you God it's fine he's dead
anyways hey Steve
Oh take take the book take the pillar
Oh lovely
oh yeah that's early whatever see
[Music]
was there any more anger in that room I
should probably not
Wow just remember we need a lion for us
get my coins in here also
let's just put
how to make this like a quick for that
side item
Oh
is there any against this one Oh today
tonight and save my game now let's make
a new one just in case there's not much
meatballs there's a bit rubbish 20
pounds bloody hell : thank you so much
that's so unexpected thank you so much I
hope everything is going well it is now
thank you
oh wait I was first I don't like this
dance I think I need to upgrade the fan
fun dance um maybe I usually dance with
my legs right so I'm not used to doing
things in my hands
I usually just make on my legs that's
like my dance move
hey this why cuz I'm writing my
dissertation and it's all about horror
games Hey
and play our control dresses developer
control and now you just I can't stop
thinking about like player agency new
narrative dissonance and I'm playing
this game and I'm like oh yeah I can't
stop analyzing things she's just wanna
have fun with it I'll have to make
videos on them though cuz it is really
really interesting like I actually just
love
hey Emma what is in these clown doors
locked contaminated
very contaminated
oh my god you're you're you're a big boy
you know what I'm just gonna run screw
you I'm like really contaminated right
now
go
no pooping off oh come on mumbles so I
can hang you up it screw it's for its
fertile I'm really contaminated I need
to get out it's all off balls balls
balls balls oh my god ow I just poked
myself in the eye ha ha like I swear the
shots when you were making a difference
in these ones crying fit now
so I imagined you dancing shaking your
legs awkwardly any party like hey guys
what's up that is actually what I do I'm
just on the dance floor and everyone
else is like shaking their booties and
I'm just like yeah oh no actually I do a
pretty good robot as well I've gotta say
maybe they can be a thing I'll show you
next time okay do I have a moose pick it
up pick it up base drop who's then that
who's Nannette Oh guys like seriously
nothing affects them and it's really
irritating oh yeah I don't think I can I
don't think I can like I don't know
this this because this guy is going to
come on no way no point trying to kill
it cuz it's not gonna work
yep yep I can't see yep it's very dark
oh hello oh I'm just go back to the
other freakin gay okay just kill me kill
me kill me kill me cuz I need to go
through the other gate and get my get my
night vision so go on I'm allowing you
what's taking you so long
kill me already yeah
as she took them quite a while so let's
go back to your place I think I was just
being stupid and like stepping in traps
or something because it said that I
acquired nitrogen and that was a dead
end because I didn't have the night
vision so I needs the night vision who's
in the net who got Fatman Scoop stuck in
my head now oh oh stop playing keep them
moving
stop playing keep it moving keep it
moving moving moving okay no not this
place go back alright I'm just gonna do
this everywhere it's too late
how many coins do I need for this
I don't know how many oh just one I got
one
I got one this is good there this one
Oh said three now did it always say
three
it was very pixelated fine damn it
I coulda just run in there I got the
antique key key coined whatever right
sorry for wasting your time
sit back okay this way the choir night
vision look out for traps
I think it's if I step on these yeah
that makes sense
oh my sweet sweet mama
okay
okay very good she says and then she's
nuts Ronnie okay let's just not run this
estate stay careful are there like
okay I'm scared to go forward you don't
know what the trap
what's this oh okay gotcha
aha I learn from my mistakes that's all
I can do
is something there
is something there excuse me
is something there
ah very confused right now something
okay I think I need it I think it needs
like okay yeah yeah yeah right I've done
that enough now I think it needs like an
energy so so I'm gonna follow these
wires trying to figure out what they
need
huh
hmm I can hardly see what can't you me
something here would be what do you guys
think
just tell Chris and bring up the
brightness by here of time thanks for
joining they okay find the night vision
in another room wait they're not
actually pick it up from that prize room
[Music]
down the lane
I thought I acquired it like when I
first got in right no dammit
obviously not what do I get it from then
huh bye Emma
by Mustafa okay okay so obviously not
this one
gotta find special bullets for that
place where else did I try is there
another thing up here amel that place I
need the night vision as well can't get
in there it's blocked
I'm very confused anyone got any ideas I
swear when I first went in there I told
me that I had attained good night vision
did it really wrong
apparently Tabriz says someone had set
you free other youtubers to help him
with that
how did he do it what do I do why do I
go what is my goal
nobody knows let's get back in here and
just see what happens
don't think that climber will be open
hey buddy do you have night vision
things for me no
maybe down here again because you know I
miss my friend the monster I don't know
trying to go go to the other pooja I got
a feeling it's probably I can't go this
way come on I'm scared of this monster I
don't want to see him again
yep
hey friend just wanna see it the clown
doors open he runs so fast no it's not
gonna be is it nope nope nope nope
Bulls oh you're so big oh you're
intimidating this okay I'm quick and
nimble cuz I'm Chris Redfield you can
never catch me
yeah she isn't guys to me
okay I'm going to look for this other
blue doctor is it the one I just went
through though as in the ones that needs
the nitrogen as well maybe I missed it
because I was running past all those
creatures
yes
that's black dog that's a green girl
oh is that blue
he's it other blue doll though cuz I
just need him that one he's a red door a
green door wait can I go through here
no on the door what other door that's
where I came from
something pick up ammo yes I'm very
confused about this
guys I think you lying to me I don't
think there is one we say the flashlight
the night vision see the green door okay
so it is here but the things that I
can't kill great let me just save the
game again and be annoying just because
I picked up a lot ammo now and I think I
think it's good if I go do this also one
sec I need to pop to the toilet
don't judge me oh I will be right back
[Music]
I'm back
[Music]
okay bite
let's try this again
Grindle
I just don't know if I can even kill
these guys
and then like I've got to worry because
I'm contaminated as well it's it's
contaminated I'm not yet but I could be
if I hang around
yeah use oh my god Oh [ __ ] he
doesn't die
oh my god it's true this great great
just what I like
now
thank you
don't take them um yes no how would it
be in here in hardly see it isn't these
contaminating
hey I'm in the dark right now oh go away
[Music]
Tammany because my head is doing
it's to like to see I know it is oh my
god ah there's a door
ah stop stop things whoa okay I'm so
contaminated there right yeah
I don't use them
over here
you know most
four handguns
right so if I use this but
ah no just be easy task of going back
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
uh-huh my god
hey I feel like the Joker is here right
No
where do I find
hello
I guess maybe huh the old up up
oh the arrows okay wait what does the
arrows shakin
I'll turn up
well it's nice of him to kind of like if
it's close
Oh God screw you go away
ah
I'm going to just wipe it Oh gonna give
you
I'm still in - Tommy its own though
doesn't really affect me much just
hello a little connector get off of my
face where the hell you just jump around
health got enough coins
oh sorry I can't see cuz my lights in
the way again just standing up now
anyway I'm gonna contaminate our get
going
shy hello oh can I kill them
this issue
Oh
okay
yeah
wastin marmo much power can i hack you
shop okay
I'm being way too slow fine
nope nope no no
that doesn't look safe
how are you it uh which way Oh none of
me I'm going the wrong way I don't want
to need a good punching Oh God
this is a very stressful sorry I'm not
talking by Mont majid I am but just not
making much then I've already been this
way thank you
oh no no no no no I thought about you
guys
okay how do I get my jollies how home
he's Thomas he's coming
where is exit gosh show me the way to
freedom
now the tunnels
one punch we put here right so let me
get my boundaries
Lala okay this is like
I think it's a better I think these days
up there
so good it actually is as well isn't it
oh you know what I just got a crawled I
forgot about this I thought they would
only work if maybe I use these as my
cover
how
the way out but they keep on respawning
oh hi
I really actually don't know this is the
way it came from
there's literally nowhere if you do this
[Applause]
okay whatever I'm gonna go down here no
one does what I'm supposed to do I don't
know what I'm supposed to do the only
way how it scenes knocked off by three
turrets so let's just go down this way
this tower don't see me hard and also
I've already tried to shoot them
shooting terrorists doesn't work
no maybe here
Oh God all right leave me be
cuz attend on the power ah yeah just
scream and everything will be okay
Shai I don't have any um medicine no no
like you did I will get that one day
nope nope anyone wanted good hand
oh my god two-in-one yes unless you
don't have any oh my god how do I manage
that I don't know I'm about to die oh
I'm about to get there East everything's
this is good this is good news okay
yourself an alibi
did okay I want to pick up something
more in the end of it um I'm gonna save
but not over myself one sec let me get
the coins on here yeah I've got enough
oh sweet oh I should have enough already
that's reader okay thank you and use it
oh just save it but honest wanna say one
purpose I did pretty badly there I don't
know how I managed that bye Kevin
hey Jim Hawks temari's can be good
sometimes I was on steroids for about a
year because I got balls in my nose and
it was medicine but he didn't tell me it
was stories until he was like oh you've
been on this for years she probably
stopped taking me now but you know got
me hedge what am i doing now
this way
ah much better feel so much
you don't have any health don't forget
that but if you don't have any help
oh I didn't see those before I must have
just been a flix I didn't I think I did
run into one actually
[ __ ] Sakas door - like the other thing
oh I should infuse that I'm oh really
hope I find some more that I'm gonna be
well annoyed at myself because I thought
that he was one of those things
[Music]
um okay so this is a puzzle give me
things cuz I need things
Oh
stay away that'll come in handy though
if there's a horde of them okay now I
need I need to push you out of the way
[Music]
oh it's where should I go
does anything even here oh there we go
okay so this is another room that will
be locks ah it's the clown
oh my god this is cool this is very cool
hello let me stop you stop moving I want
to kill you of my night this is not
working
turn around
Hey close close close it off so close
I'm close enough close close
hey I got this oh my god why do I always
see that to myself okay now I got this
hey you okay oh god I'm coming
alright look around for loop because you
need them you need some that special
armor because you're a freaking idiot
and you use it up they're not gonna get
me more do all this again
you're up
come on
okay
look at look at wicked wicked
I was just baked you fell for it this is
something over here
I'm just trying to join I loop loads
that hey guys don't judge me I do care
about him I just want to see if this
loop which there is
[Applause]
hey ro I love that you turn everything
into a song I do die hey God I'm coming
oh no apparently my quality is bad let's
have a look oh dear oh dear let's see if
it gets better it's working again no it
still says it's bad I mean it happens to
move for an hour and a half because
maybe I could stream again tomorrow
night if it's not gonna work and I can
see if I did need that ammo and if I did
then I will just redo that part again
when did this come out to day who day
came out today
Jake Goldsmith let's have a look how bad
is it
I'm gonna play it myself and see
oh it looks alright oh it's back to
being good sweet okay
let's carry on
but yeah I really really hope I don't
need that ammo
okay so that's not I just don't know
where else to go if we're not gonna go
and see that guy
okay so
not gonna go and touch him
I can't go over there because I can't
jump there is something there right
[Music]
I'm not falling for your tricks give me
something
yes cotton we got more of that nice ammo
I mean we might need some more but at
least we've got some
okay
now I can pick up the body or do I just
leave it but didn't think it's actually
a dude right it's just it's just a hoax
don't leave your comrades okay finally
actually is in
hey hey you still with us yeah it's you
Thanks
I was beginning to think we've been left
behind Chris is always here to help a
fellow team member up good man you
shouldn't be the way I already knew that
but I'll let you think him up you pop I
got your back
[Music]
I think that is why you need to take
Novoa first real time playing games
three men Lucas three of my men dead
because of you
[Music]
to be fair though as long as I've got a
belt on I can tie it okay we got a
situation here
which where do I go wastin time
Hey hello miss you
not really oh Jesus
come on come on come on open up it nice
safe now that'd be a good idea what
about all your clown does get your
canisters of liquid nitrogen nearby
where are the canisters
Monisha for the nation
by
[Music]
not wasting my ammo on you my man I was
something bigger to deal with here he is
not you
Oh oh my gosh
how do I use these can I use these now
oh did I even pick it up
nevermind oh because of yeah I'm loose
I don't know what I'm doing well boom
okay you're looking at this man
hello away come on come on
no take it back I need to use this one
he's been a bit maybe I'll find
something good
Oh God how do I get into this frickin
frickin that broom no no no that's not
going to do anything this guy I need to
use the other ammo Oh give it climb up
stop oh my god I'm gonna die oh my god
I'm gonna die oh my god I'm gonna die no
I need to use the other animals
spin on me oh I have no more frickin
with this
I actually like in certainties am I
supposed to kill this man
no more restaurants and I have no medkit
please sighs please be dying please be
dying
Oh God
yeah I did ah oh so stressful
you took my Christmas oh oh okay so I
can just use that to have her open
okay and then I can use like normal
grenades and stuff like that
okay punch it in the head
[Music]
come here big momma
okay bunch of bunch of bunch of us whoa
punch it don't do that
let's go sit down no punch it oh my god
just frickin punch it in the face oh god
why do I always do this oh yeah off of
my face
No
[Music]
pretty pissing me off dying it and then
changes why would you just stop spitting
okay I don't know
come on they're right I have no ammo I
do actually
Hey
[Music]
today while they sat down that corridor
I don't care I don't have enough time
that show of the escalator up the
escalator and see what happens oh we're
going down we're going down I think it
happens then you go down
I did not get those stuff that I needed
wet
did I
where's the stuff I need
yes
where the hell is it did I get it oh not
just warm I passed it oh did I get it no
I didn't
oh my god I'm gonna have to do that
again I'm very confused about where this
stuff was huh
guys what the hell oh oh yeah I don't
know why I'm going know what I'm doing
I'm I'm just gonna get whatever like I'm
guessing I've got it or whatever I don't
know
I'm very confused I was just following
the path but I don't think I've got it
yeah I came up from there okay what yeah
people like you [ __ ] up where was it
oh it's just the game but it's a
freaking annoying game where the hell is
it oh it's my dad oh my god guys just
now I'm a mite mumbling yeah I'm fine
I'm fine
hey I did it what times is bad
was there another clown doll that I have
checked out yet
oh my god this heaven
that was crazy don't be stupid but I
still did it getting intense okay
time to activate they'll be
thank you
only just Leslie
yeah punch three
oh my god
I need to use my grenades how do I cut
something in quickselect though let's
get question you're gonna play lny of a
massive honestly probably not only cuz I
don't really play games twice and I
played that game aged the gum it's good
game though how do I change like what's
here
no I don't know ah okay
you can use it but can I move it move it
yes that's that hmm
there's that one phone now yeah okay
I got
other than problem
okay very impressive my friend hello
Jonathan
let's just see how impressive baby truly
wastin ah okay
yeah explode I didn't do what have you
gonna be is this van
Oh
stay down
Oh without me - yeah let me get behind
you such a tiny speed just smoke these
Oh a little um I don't know one day what
that you're doing you have no I'm next
I think it's about time I wrap up this
dream because one sec oh I need to
choose oh my gosh
BRB
you
ah hit with very funny funny for you
yeah no I don't think I can play this
game anymore
ah so try once more and then if I die I
die if I die I'll sing a little song for
you guys but I just don't know if I can
do it I don't know if I can do it for
you guys let me check doo doo doo doo
doo doo
um okay
come pose
make sure I have a grenade available
maybe not use the incinerator grenades
they're probably a bad idea because I'm
in such a small space maybe instead of
an incinerator and use the other one
okay let's try and do this
thanks : glad you believe me to be fair
I don't know I'm trying to be fair
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know which ones which when I do
this you know I'm probably not gonna be
using my knife so maybe I'll take the
hour but primont but I've got too many
characters just like stun grenade there
like that one it's good in theory
I'm just gonna get out of the way I want
my good again other way yeah yeah it's
very pretty well let's put it there
let's not use all of our grenades at
once it's done let's just see how
impressive
[ __ ] wrong imma like it Brittany needs
to give you better understanding what I
was hit you hit you in the he takes so
long oh my god I hate you
hey hey
this area you're so tiny
no I totally got lucky let me get back
upstairs
that's my safe though oh my god what is
happening don't get Miami look at the
cat see Wow
Jesus 70 head okay you sir these were
these and you leave one of them feel
safe she will use a molasses
please explode oh my god but not on me
you weirdos you know what screw you guys
I'm gonna just yeah already you know
turds I'm going hello oh yeah my knife
um just add to that then to that wasting
time
oh my god what am i doing now I don't
freaking know I don't have a clue where
am I going guys out the way please
you're totally massive
maybe not attack here
stop your shenanigans what like be dying
yes thank you for your belief that was
you that was you you're gonna kill me
just kill me
shut the [ __ ] up
Christopher this
Oh Oh my laptop's gone to sleep I can't
even see what you're saying oh my god
folks do I do
how about you make it more obvious yeah
cuz I don't know what I'm supposed to be
doing maybe an ancillary something or
other
now I'm dead under
oh oh wait
okay let me wake back up this and see if
you guys have any clue while is supposed
to do huh down naturally oh crap
no okay hopefully this won't put me
right back to the start of killing all
those things oh please they don't want
to kill all those things again I don't
want to go this gun is over there what
is it baby died oh wait you're good news
sympathy from me [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
one of the we've got to open
ha
you saw SmartZone get me out of here
whoa damn damn damn damn damn
the game gives me hot he thinks I'm dead
this might be our chance who do you send
it to we're still guns this is good
we're in an actual environment like I'm
going underground
the testing
hmm yeah I don't really want to go in
there
I'll put you out of your misery again
why because I can oh my god
Dong's
mom and dad
so these were definitely want to see
women
ah
I knew you were gonna wake up like I
just knew it I'm sick of this guy Lucas
they just gave him my job as leave
researcher who do you think I am why do
I stand for graduate with a master's in
microbiology you have to work under this
lunatic all he does is mess around with
the test subjects make them all fight
each other and doing unnecessary
autopsies he's sick he knows nothing
about the e-series new to my seat's
potential I'm going to report his
behavior yeah I mean unless that's what
they wanted and they just realized that
you were too sane to do the job you know
sometimes that happens you get turned
away from just because you're
overqualified um that is that is a thing
and they think that you will not like be
a hassle but maybe change the way
because you'll be intelligent enough to
see the flaws and they don't want you to
see the flaws so they hire people less
qualified so they will follow orders
easier there's a thing
Lucas see playing with dolls
and I said this is awesome
no odd burg hi thanks for watching I
don't have a VR headset but I would love
to play this game in VR Oh though it be
apps like especially the meal scene at
the beginning of the game which thing
that'd be amazing here when your hand
gets hacked off I love watching people's
reactions to that pop do you think
you're gonna die and then you're like
wait I'm still playing but I don't have
a hand you just holding it I guess or
the blood going everywhere okay I don't
know what okay I'm ready for you oh
Jesus hello can I jump through here
where did you go what am i doing what is
this I don't know
in color I have to care about spending
an ETL should be long
get this get it get the hell out of it
look fake that's the first not pick up
pound this DLC I know there's a say a
game thing but I'm just living by a
feeder to go
I killed off all the connections
researchers they were poking around ever
and they weren't supposed to when I
wasn't looking but I knew exactly what
they're up to you probably didn't like
having to report to me so I threw them
in a cage with some molded the a [ __ ]
that bouncing back to their lives
I'm just worried I won't be able to hold
back from laughing when I make the
report they met with an unfortunate
accident probably good times and out to
cut ties with the connections I'm the
only one who can really make good use of
evidence involved yes Evelyn the
grandmother
you heard you've heard that theory right
though the grandma is Evelyn I'm Shirley
I'm Shirley credit anyway let's save the
game because that grandma is really
creepy she was honestly the scariest one
an oldie
oh yeah forgot ya guys odd but oh my god
I don't think okay there's another door
inside out [ __ ] it is one of the game
developers I interviewed they made a PR
game and it's a side-scrolling
platformer it's quite interesting you
can watch it on gaming with yak man X my
secondary channel oh yeah it doesn't
make sense like when you explain it so
you got to see it so just go go watch
the interview it's cool
wait which way do I go I don't know it's
too many churches too many choices
ah player agency uh dissertation coming
through okay yeah so I go the other way
see there is the players what
wait now is the other way Oh
so I'm guessing if I try to go up there
at the beginning it would have been lots
okay sorry
it's the way I came where did he run off
to
that is literally the only way that I
can go right
maybe I'm just gonna run for it
based on shoes
oh you have no ammo oh you're trolling
me ah it gave him so much time
[Applause]
got your emails
we know you're funneling info to someone
your friends the connections know about
this they don't strike me as the
forgiving oh yeah
just shut up and accepted Lucas
like
since we got here
I'm so glad I didn't stop playing now
thank you for having faith in me guys I
would have given up
Oh yum-yum-yum-yum yum-yum-yum
my favorite type of monster
[Music]
hey let me reload and then hit you a
wannabe and then hit you we're gonna be
and then maybe give you a little whack
ohh
[Music]
I'm trying oh my god hi
oh sure not my job to do that okay I
think you see that week on this week on
this we can do this come on I need
oxygen
I was my own Andy don't be so rude okay
now
one name something like
no don't waste the freakin dollar you
were supposed to have changed
oh my god oh my god now I just have a
paddy okay one more time
Oh
we live
just let me - um okay
nice let's go in
ah
[Music]
Oh thoughts oh yeah run into this face
nothing bad will happen
oh why does he always change the
freaking ammo so slowly
[Music]
that's what you say oh my god
I know
hey mother where are you what you don't
wanna do that okay
wait one sec one sec one sec let me do
something okay now let me set your fire
Wow nice
Oh scheisse oh my god
hey chill out you know the one playing
let me play that what play oh so
annoying I gave you that one because it
was so funny he said that's the correct
answer was me cool what what are you
guys talking about
[Music]
okay we're gonna try once more and then
I'm so even if I don't win I'm gonna go
bad and I will try again let's take some
more after work I don't want to beat but
you know when you play too much and then
need more ammo fine
special ah okay since it's an omen this
is the special
so maybe should I save the special oh my
god and also by the way this is running
like this is how fast he runs that you
guys like wow now I am trying butter you
just don't run on fairs
but it's gonna jump out
Oh only nine months only nine
[Music]
balls balls post of all right
[Music]
oh my god I'm cheap go out now mister
into the game
I can't do anything
Oh wonderful
let me just run right past ya and then I
need to reload lovely oh my god
oh my god make them pissing on me
go get you up Go Go Go boy
wait I had to war over wait wait wait
wait wait hold up wait a minute okay
game over
thanks guys I'm really happy I didn't
think I was gonna be able to video
thanks I'm lucky
wow that was boom right well hey that
long did I actually just finish the GLC
good I think we did any good here
alright I'm on my way
[Music]
come on please damn well well well I did
it guys I did it I'm really proud of
myself I know I'm the best but you know
I do one night why why is it so sure I
don't think it's gonna be that short
um but ya know I think that game was
like to appease all of the Resident Evil
players that liked the action elements
of Resident Evil cuz at first it was
kind of an where it was never a proper
survival horror but you know as more
anticipation what's about the corner and
then it starts I bring in like co-op and
it was just very much runny shooting
bunny shootie which is what this this
DLC was this would look attacks
deflected none
I got no skills zero skills item box
open six files obtained 609 mm-hm
antique toys I don't know half of them
where where are they hiding
Sam realizes used zr0 healing items and
11 and a steroid of course I am locked
professional difficulty don't think I
need that Thor's hammer site sweet is
there any more cutscenes no nice okay
well
in that case uh yeah congratulations
thank you I got very short I didn't
expect to finish it in one night but uh
uh uh these games made me so stressed
I got apologize for like my sister again
so I just get written into games like
horror games actual games
I don't know just get very like shawnee
you do it too right maybe it's not as
powerful as me but this is why I do live
streams and stuff like honestly what
those thing it gave my friend's house
and they were just like you need to
start YouTube channel or something
because you've talked non-stop anything
it's like yeah why not
anyway you guys are talking about what
Chris Redfield this is I've heard a lot
of different speculation because some
people were like that's Chris Maston
other people were like no he looks
completely different and I like I said I
haven't played as an eagle since the
first ones on they said one I think I
played some PlayStation 2 ones but I was
back when the zombies were quite slow
it was more like stealthy I guess like
scary then then I'm running funny should
do actually but yeah sometime
Jimmy makes you talk yeah I talk at the
game there's a gate like really immersed
in it and I'm like shouting and just
like getting all the car yeah I always
talk when I play games
what gaming consoles did you own I not
many because but my mum said that when I
was a kid apparently I was on the
computer from like the age of three and
she was really worried about me because
I wouldn't get off the computer so she
didn't want to buy me any game consoles
so um I got a gameboy color and then I
got a ps1 then I got a ps2 and then I
bought myself an Xbox 360 and then I got
the PF thought so yeah I didn't have
anything cool like the nares or anything
like that
because my mum was worried that I'd
spend all my term on it she's probably
right so instead I went outdoors on a
country's and stuff
what's the plan - Christmas Michael
going home after my dissertation
firsthand in and spending some time with
my mom she's come home from Portugal so
I think we're gonna spend Christmas with
my grandma I don't know baby here just
Christmas is family time which is nice
because I don't always get to see my
family play the game already I already
played it mister most skis I've just
completed it but yeah I guess some time
wait pretend to me if I can sing cuz
I've been screaming my lungs out um this
could be a nice little backing track to
my song yeah why not I'll sing you um
pretty games good totally stress video
games cool stress like this one but no
you're right you're right if you've had
a really bad day and you just like
shooting things it's good I used to do
that in left4dead left I really want to
play love for Dad
so many games that I really really miss
from like my childhood I've still got
them but I don't have the consoles with
me it's like for instance a Gregory's
horror show IV I've been waiting to play
that for the longest time it's on ps2
but yeah it's not late and left for dead
I think I'm gonna get that back when I'm
back home so my friend's got an Xbox
it's always like I can take my left for
dead or we could play it because that's
the best games player friends as well I
love playing left 4 dead
yeah let me play a little song along the
run a place the new ones there's a play
one new one and then I'll see how I feel
I played the others my voice is strained
I would play left with that for my fans
but I don't know how because I don't
have a computer and it's not on ps4 so
[Music]
oh my trip to USA so that was actually
for work but I got one day of exploring
yeah I was good that was really friendly
I made a vlog about it so you'll see the
vlog but I got bedbugs which wasn't good
I got given a a king room which I've
never had before so I was like oh my
gosh good with cheap basically I'm a
videographer that's what I do
alongside this and they wanted me to
film a conference it was a mess
for like yes I went to Philadelphia to
film this conference I just had a week
of three deadlines in uni I've been
acting as well for my friend's film
production and then I've got there's
like majorly jet-lagged but the hotel
was lovely and it had had its own
swimming pool and stuff and I had the
whole pool to myself I swear that was
the highlight of majority not I didn't
love America I did but just knowing that
I could be swimming on my own was like
no best I loved it
and um yeah so I got got there and I
woke up and I had bedbugs I got bitten
on my cheek I woke up and they were like
falling on my bed
there's crumbs and then I found that
Mel's like I've got bedbugs in my bed I
think I need to be moved and the woman
was just like what kind of dog is it and
I was like there was a bedbug and she's
like what does it look like it was like
it's clear with blood in it and she was
like how do you even know it's blood I
was like just believe me it's a bedbug
okay and then they came up in these dogs
back months and they moved me to another
room and by the time I'd like wasted
most of my day but it was okay like I
mean I made a vlog about it and stuff
and then I I went to the swimming pool
when walking on bear and then they look
to see Christmas markets and then I
worked it didn't 18-hour day in one day
oh my god guys in this ridiculous I was
up at 6 a.m. I finish at 10 p.m. I was
like dead to the world and then everyone
was going out drinking Naz like what's
wrong with you
they're like older than me I was like I
can't I can't
I need to go to bed but no it was really
interesting because basically I was
working with my coworker kai and he's a
videographer do and he had to go off to
this like fancy Emile place to set up
the film equipment there and I was gonna
film a small awards before the main
rewards which was up the bigger place
and I was there for like one battery cuz
they're like oh yeah one it won't take
that long and it took like two hours
turns out was supposed to do something
before the awards that I wasn't really
Todd and I was like oh my god you got it
improvising these things and then I was
taking all the pictures of the awards
and everything and they have one major
picture left to do of all the finalists
up on stage and they were all like
posing and I had a red flashing light I
was like please just just be okay
because I was only left with one extra
battery that was charging because it was
dead and all okay it's gonna be okay
let's you just like to take it and it
died and I was like I've got two choices
either I pretend to take the photo or I
run get the other battery and just yeah
so I ran I just like legged it out of
this massive hallway this girl in like
high-heeled boots and stuff because I'd
suggest all nice and fancy taking at the
battery and then run back through and
everyone was just like smile at me like
what did she do I know it's just like
yeah keep smiling but I think this photo
oh my god I'm an idiot but the CEO of
the company came up and said well done
so I think I made the right choice I
look like an idiot but it made them
smile made them smile for the picture
and I did get the picture in the end so
just goes to show even if you're gonna
make an embarrassment of yourself do it
if it's the right thing to do
people will notice anyway but yeah
there'll be a whole video on on that
kind of stuff ever kill you soda
hi she leave it to the catch they need a
fresh start
be careful what you say she no longer
feels the swing look at her eyes stings
when up sorta [ __ ] i watch to weaken the
time she lost when takes but like
seconds since both your pants class
surfer that's what i keeping out this
cop brother buddy here keeps him about
it was forever
[Music]
she likes to think she's clever sorry
for a nickel thought your breath when
you're so fickle
hand it over her heart bouncing heavy
and brittle soda for a key to regain a
dignity so loan in a box and by yours
truly this is just the story of a girl
who sort of heart
now she's forgotten she's kind of fresh
to be careful what you sing she no
longer feels the same look in her eyes I
see the stains
[Music]
love can't you sing as you can tear em
free it's here's my PA try it sure but
you I'll plead my love why did you
choose salat you could offer your ties
but you laughs one loose love as you
faith I have to say
[Music]
this is just stirring up a girl who's so
hot
now she's who captain she's gotta that
is it first night guys oh gosh
do note arms there you go it thank you
so much for staying with me tonight
thank you so much for all your support
and faith in my skills thank you for
making me play on normal mode and not
easy thank you for chatting to me thank
you for everyone who donated just thank
you and yes that's an original I think
I'll be uploading that one next actually
I think I'll be recording it over the
weekend
yeah so Oh time for bed
I've got work in the morning and yeah I
hope you have a lovely day or evening
but I will say good night or good bye to
you one-on-one so anyone I can see in
the chat you're gonna say goodbye to you
right now okay so goodbye officer Naruto
goodbye Alex Williams Suns adventures
goodbye Jim hope - bye Lucas goodbye no
mercy goodbye Michael
goodbye Dan goodbye I'm here goodbye
Becca goodbye Kai goodbye i don''t did I
already say that goodbye :
goodbye my city Leighton goodbye Jim
goodbye
yeah I think everyone goodbye dubs girl
if I miss you I'm so sorry but good bye
to you anyway and good bye to all of you
lacquers in the string have a lovely day
or evening Oh shite that's not how I
finish first of all burns bye